au numéro un il ya ahmad historique a
dit ce soir allume le feu pour nous
johnny le très bel hommage du vélodrome
et des marseillais à johnny hallyday
puisque ce week-end les clubs de ligue 1
le championnat de france de football ont
rendu hommage à johnny hallyday c'était
aussi le cas de l'om et hier soir lors
de son match contre saint-etienne
regardez il ya même un super tifo de la
part des supporters bravo à regarder
c'est magnifique parce que c'est vrai
que ça c'était un moment oui j'ai raté
un très bon moment moi j'étais au parc
des princes est vrai que eux aussi
célébrer chaque but on est par un
extrait de johnny hallyday et c'était
beau parce qu'un des plus grands
concerts de johnny était au parc des
princes et donc on voyait sur scène
johnny hallyday sur grand écran et en
même temps on était dans le parc désert
et glacial et c'était c'était très
émouvant
alors le numéro 9 donc on a classé
numéro 9 c'est juste incroyable mariah
carey à bercy a rendu hommage à johnny
elle a chanté en français que je t'aime
elle est par ailleurs voilà rien après
tout ce que dit gérard louvin et et par
les besoins de match rendue à johnny
donc il ya une mariah carey regarde
sa fair play besoin c'est très bien
qu'elle ait fait ça je trouve ça très
très bouleversant elle a démarré comme
ça c'est formidable et il ya aussi
vianney pour y parler ses goules benoît
c'était chez laurent delahousse hier et
regarder ont senti qu'il était très très
ému vianney rien coupables
le voleur le le violente
j'ai oublié
il me
mais
il
j'ai oublié de vivre
aussi il ya eu beaucoup de tweets en
numéro huit s'est les stars qui étaient
présentes et il ya quelqu'un qui a dit
je vois toutes les plus grandes stars
françaises chialer je vous jure j'ai du
mal à retenir mes larmes aussi vous y
étiez un an bernard montiel et c'est
vrai que l'hommage de johnny a rassemblé
beaucoup de monde samedi
on a nos tombes non plus voir de
nombreuses personnalités regarde voilà
donc alors je vous les meilleurs vannes
de toute l'année dans mon oreille
régulier on n'a pas le magnéto par
contre on à bernard manqué la personne
et la d'entrée qui avait beaucoup
beaucoup de monde au bernard louis
c'était magnifique je crois que c'était
un moment de communion extraordinaire la
france entière moi je vous dis je
évidemment je suis la madeleine invité
par david et laura et j'ai même filmé
cette scène de cette foule il y avait
plus d'un million de personnes étaient
réunies et le temps d'aller de chez moi
vous savez d'aller jusqu'à la madeleine
je suis allé à pied et les gens me
chanter des chansons il me touche et me
disait transmettez en brasse et sylvie
nathalie l'éthicien c'était très très
émouvant je m'était arrivé dans un état
parce que c'était très difficile
et puis j'ai vu j'ai vu tout le monde ce
qui m'a fait plaisir aussi bien en
arrivant je suis tombé sur philippe
lavil il y avait non loin y avait jean
louis aubert il y avait thomas dutronc
thomas dutronc a qui s'approchait
d'ailleurs son papa qui est pas très en
forme en ce moment
j'ai vu tout le monde tout le métier
était là ça m'a fait plaisir j'ai vu de
rigueur évidemment bouleversé et il y
avait il ya eu des tweets aussi drôle
parce que non vraiment vous le livre là
tout le monde était ému il ya même des
gens qui voient l'âme qui par l'humour
voilà essayer un petit peu de désamorcer
exactement désamorcée et essayer de
douala ii et à quelqu'un qui a envoyé un
tweet regarder
merci bon gars thibault qui a dit john à
l'idée aura même réussi à faire
apparaître françois hollande et julie
gayet influent ciellement encore
notables c'était la première à part
quand ils vont dîner chez géraldine
gagner non mais c'est vrai pour la
première fois on a pu voir françois
hollande et julie gayet ensemble est-ce
qu'on à l'extrait non mais on à bernard
ben oui on la regarde
on
pendant qu'on a on a classé numéro 7 6
les bikers qui envahissent et changer de
métier grégory coupet même lot l'ancien
vraiment donc de l'ancien gardien de but
de l'ol qui a mis quel hommage
magnifique bravo les bikers l'un des
moments les plus forts de la cérémonie
ce que vous avez regardé jean marc
bédier
ben alors nous on était en tournée j'ai
regardé ça sur mon téléphone j'ai fou
happé par par par l'émission c'était
magnifique genre qui a eu aucune fausse
note je trouve c'est vrai très sobre est
génial et donc du coup on a tous regardé
mais comme ça complètement hypnotisés
par les chansons qu'on entendait les
gens criaient journée qui l'a motivé je
suis assez d'accord révisé pas c'est pas
facile et je voulais vraiment rajouter
c'est pas facile parce que nous on est
des humoristes et en ce moment il se
passe tellement de choses c'est pas
facile encore de rigoler sur scène avec
tout ce qui se passe et j'ai un g1
personnages auront spectacle s'appelle
jacquier qui est fan de johnny johnny
même et ça a été très compliqué pour moi
mercredi de faire ce sketch parce que
j'ai senti dans la salle que on n'avait
pas le droit de rigoler ce soir là et
j'ai quand même tenu à faire le sketch
et et j'ai senti ouais j'ai senti les
applaudissements après parce que j'ai
rajouté une petite phrase dans le sketch
qui accable qui a je pense fait réagir
le public et les applaudissements
derrière était surréaliste j'ai jamais
entendu des applaudissements que c'est
vraiment le public voilà était derrière
johnny quoi qu'elle joue son super et
mieux school avait connu johnny parce
que les pas du tout pas donné comme nom
voilà vous étiez en fait j'ai commencé
ce métier je me suis dit un jour je
serai connu et je rencontrerai johnny et
j'ai pas eu le temps voilà j'ai plein
d'amis en commun qui m'ont envoyé des
textos mercredi et samedi qui m'ont dit
johnny aurait adoré jacky voilà et ça
m'a vraiment touché comment va sa fin
gros bisous
est clair voilà ça va dire et jeff c'est
un garçon qui a une sensibilité
incroyable et c'est pour ça qu'en fait
voilà mêmes on accepte tout de dief vous
êtes dieu je vous dis la vérité
la fusion marque vous êtes tellement
drôle je pense que tous les fans de
johnny vont adorer
jacky voilà je vous le dis vous êtes
voilà comment c'est drôle et je pense
aussi que je suis sûr que johnny aura
adoré le personnage de dire qu'ils
regardent et les bikers qui envahissent
les champs didier regarde voilà les
images sont en train de nous parvenir
regardez c'est du direct
ce sont les motards dont on parlait tout
à l'heure qui sont en train de se mettre
en place les images aériennes sont elles
nous sont données par un hélicoptère qui
s'envolent qui survole le cortège la
dernière fois qu'on avait autant parler
de scooter en france est elle hors de la
sphère françois hollande julie gayet
regarder imaginons l'hommage à françois
hollande voit là franchement il ya eu
des trucs et extrêmement drôle en
sixième alors ce qui a fait beaucoup
réagir
c'est philippe labro qui a fait un
discours magnifique vraiment philippe
labro notre collègue de ses huit qu'on
aime énormément
et parmi les hommages dont il ya eu
celui de philippe et c'est vrai qu'il
avait il a dit que johnny avait été par
deux fois sans prendre en compte donc
jade et joy
ethias a beaucoup fait réagir mais voilà
vous allez nous dire ce que vous en
pensez vers la en plus vous y étiez
regardez johnny hallyday
qui était-il cherchons les mots à la
chimiste un voyageur un aventurier un
combattant un amoureux un biker un
général un père par deux fois alors il a
dit j'ai commis une erreur en parlant
des enfants de johnny qu'à la fin père
par deux fois erreur due à l'émotion
d'un discours viacités ensuite jade et
joy et que l'on pardonne cette boulette
qui n'a rien de méchant bien entendu je
les aime toutes les deux et leur mère
voilà philippe labro caf un discours sur
formidable vraiment et qui m'a beaucoup
ému aussi je pense que vous aussi les
shihri quelle était l'ambiance e bernard
parce que c'est vrai que nous allons
regarder la télé c'est vrai que j'étais
on était nous tease est vraiment vous
lever oui c'était c'était extrêmement
lourd évidemment c'est vraiment lourd
bon tous les ans politique était là
c'était une bonne chose de
reconnaissance pour johnny qui était
évidente mais il y avait la famille
avait sylvie vartan qui représente
tellement de choses y avait nathalie
baye david avait laura qui voyait même
pas s'exprimer tellement elle était mal
david très qui te le dise ah oui très
très digne et il y avait les enfants il
y avait les enfants des stèles hessel
était avec moi eddy mitchell aussi puis
de l'autre côté il y avait le clan un
peu laetitia boudou avec les amis aussi
de l'autre côté c'était très émouvant
très fort et j'avoue que moi je n'ai
jamais pu dire un seul mot à la messe
voyez par exemple dit la vérité bernard
moi je vous dis quand on arrive là bayat
parce que c'est vrai qu'à ligne avec
toutes ses stars tout tous ces gens
connus comment comment ça se passe ce
qu'elle est parce que moi je vous dis
qu'est-ce qui lé premier mot qu'on se
dit que quand on croise voilà on dit
quoi on dit on aimerait se rencontrer on
aurait aimé se revoir dans d'autres
circonstances question du nom jean-louis
aubert ça a été tu te rappelles avec
johnny donc ses souvenirs avec denis des
souvenirs oui avec sylvie nathalie
c'était la différence c'est juste
embrassés papa de mots dans ces cas là
moi je les aime ces femmes sont
formidables alors il ya il ya un truc
qui a fait beaucoup parler aussi et qui
a été formidable c'est les musiciens
dont les guitares east robin le mesurier
yarol poupaud que celle d'or matthieu
chedid et yodelice est aussi ils ont été
exceptionnels
voilà tout le monde indique qui voilà
qui ont dit qu'ils ont été magnifiques
et m'ont tiré les larmes c'était
magnifique regarder
l'année
ils n'ont pas dû mais il est plutôt joli
à voir
ils n'ont pas joué des titres de johnny
parce qu'ils ne voulaient pas ils ont
joué voilà du rock'n'roll voilà donc
c'était formidable
et ils ont fait un boulot c'est que
d'utilisation mais sans sa n'ont pas de
voix surtout voulait pas rater leur
évidemment c'est que des musiques de
johnny évidemment il était très
bouleversant été donné j'étais devant
eux yodelice il avait le il était ravagé
par là il était c'était émouvant un
point incroyable masbou faire jusqu'au
petit détail ou sur scène quand ils ont
joué dehors il y avait encore le pied de
micro ni joe nick et hyper touchant
c'est elle et sa moto si je vous dis
alors il ya eu un autre truc qui s'est
passé qui est grand numéro 4 des
événements là dessus c'est nolwenn leroy
carambar et journaliste à la romya ça
passe une journaliste de france 2 samedi
alors que la journaliste disait ne pas
entendre nolwenn à cause du bruit la
chanteuse lui a répondu oui ceux-ci
regarder et nolwenn une fois de plus je
pète au téléphone
y'a pas de mots pour décrire ce que
j'aimais représentait devoir à tous les
français
générations confondues aussi
alors je vous la bouche que dans ton mec
parce que dean walcott qui
m
et ma librairie c'est la musique c'est
les lois qui se met re rentrer
johnny et vous avez raison contre
l'oreillette
il s'est rendu vers autrefois très
touchant et ceux qui nous ont plus
marqué sont ceux de line renaud et
patrick bruel moi pas pour elle il m'a
vraiment retourné vraiment patrick et il
ya le celui aussi de jean reno on va
démarrer donc on va regarder un extrait
du discours de patrick bruel
regardez je me réveille c'est donc vrai
mais c'est irréel
tout laissait à penser que tu était
immortel c'est quand je sais mais j'y ai
cru jusqu'à hier soir
je n'arrive pas à imaginer qu'il n'y
aura plus de johnny comme si on avait
enlevé la tour eiffel dans la nuit sauf
que tu me manqueras plus cruellement que
la vieille tour ne le ferais tu vas
faire le voyage avec jean d'ormesson
vous allez bien vous mme harel tu n'as
pas oublié de vivre johnny tu as vécu
mille vies en essayant toujours de nous
les faire partager
tu nous a aussi fait partager ta mort à
nous et à tout le public d'une manière
merveilleuse